we let the grassland seal as much as
possible
a rotational grazing plan really varies
from year to year some years I want to
try to introduce cool season grasses
some years I want to introduce legumes
that I've planted like the slicer milk
batch and stuff and the big blue stem
we're not on a set pattern we try to
shift it up every year hit a different
Paddock the last few years we've been
making smaller paddocks finding it a lot
more even grazing a lot more thorough
grazing getting grazing on the noxious
weeds our grasslands we're usually off
of those by the first of November and
then we're moving on to our cover crop
and crop residue I think about the
latest we've had our cows out was
February 1st we had to bring them home
and start feeding we ran out of places
degrees we let the grassland seal as
much as possible